So, let's dig a little bit deeper into blueprints and let's talk about construction scripts.
So, a construction script is a type of automation, which is a reason for a construction script.
It's part of the event graph.
It's got use and limitations and we will also put these lessons into practice in a workshop
example just to really drive home what a construction script is.
What is a construction script and why should we use it?
So, construction script is a special event that actor-based blueprints inherit and allows
them to perform logic before being visible.
So, whenever we compile our blueprint, the construction script will fire.
So, it can fire at editor time as well.
This means that when we have editable variables that are exposed and you can edit
in the blueprint classes, it allows you to dynamically modify this blueprint based on
logic and exposed parameters.
So, in this example here, we're creating a series of conditions that when we hit compile
and we move the blueprint, we can actually add some mesh functionality in the editor
rather than at runtime.
So, construction scripts can take a little bit of getting your head around, especially
if you're not from a programming background, but they have some really, really powerful
outcomes especially when building scenes and building sets and trying to think about how
to speed up the workflow.
Construction scripts can be a really powerful way of just really optimizing these pipelines.
So, the visual script and event graph is the event graph that runs during gameplay
including play and editor.
So, as we were referring to before, these three windows in your blueprint graph, you've
got your viewport, which you can see the visual representation of the blueprint.
You've got your event graph, which houses all the main blueprints in this firing at
runtime.
Your construction script is where you'll be putting any code that you want to happen
every time you interact on the editor level as well.
So, we can look at collision damage, movement, player interaction, events, spawning actors
in the event graph.
So, this is all stuff that's happening at runtime.
So, when the players are interacting with things, firing off events, spawning things,
these are all happening during the experience that you're creating.
The construction script, however, runs before the game is running.
Including in the level editor viewport.
So, we can add components here, we can change parameters, we can assign asset reference,
we can build geometry and other components.
When I was talking about improving processes and pipelines and thinking about tools that
you can use at editor time to improve your pipelines and processes, the construction
script is a really, really strong way of doing this.
So, by default, the construction script runs at the following time.
When the actor is first placed in the level, so if you drag and drop a blueprint into a
level, the construction script will fire.
So, by dragging and dropping from the content browser, that's what will happen.
When the blueprint class is compiled, so again, when we compile and save, the construction
script will fire.
And even when you instance the actor is moved around the level, talking about that inheritance
from before, the construction script will fire across these instance actors.
So, you can stop this by setting a run construction script to false in the class, if you don't
want that construction script firing, but it will by default fire on instance actors.
And then when the level is loaded with an instance actor in it.
So, it will also fire when you hit play, but the powerful functionality is strong during
editor time.
So, it's one thing talking about the functionality of construction scripts and especially knowing
how complex they can be.
The theory is great and good to know, but let's dive into creating a blueprint with
some construction script functionality so you can see exactly what's happening here.
So, we're in our editor, we're just in a default map.
It can be whatever map you need.
What we're going to do though is we're going to create a new blueprint class.
So, I'm going to in my content, I'm going to have a BP folder.
Again, just to keep organized, you don't need to do this.
It's not going to break anything if you don't, but I like to have a blueprint folder.
I'm going to right click inside of this empty space.
I'm going to go to blueprint class at the top here.
And I will select actor, which is going to be nine times out of ten, most likely the
type of functionality.
You just want an actor-based blueprint for this example.
And I'm just going to call this BP underscore construction example.
It doesn't matter what you call this.
Something to highlight is I like to use BP underscore as a naming convention.
And again, whatever prefix you want for your blueprints, that's fine.
As long as they're consistent across the team that you're working with or across the projects
that you're working on, I would keep a consistent prefix there.
But either way, we'll double click this blueprint to open it.
And then the first thing we want to do is go to our construction script.
So, our construction script is on the top of the window here, just inside this viewport.
So, clicking construction script and you should see this construction script.
So, I'm just left mouse dragging over that.
Now, to move around my blueprint, I'm just holding down right mouse button.
I want to create a variable, first of all.
So, I'm going to go to my variables tab on the left-hand side here.
I'm going to click plus.
And I'm going to call this how many bushes.
So, I'm not going to put a space in my variable name.
But what I am going to do is I'm going to capitalize each letter.
And I'll show you why I do that in a second.
So, I've just hit enter and then click on Boolean.
And what I want to do is I want to make sure it's an integer.
So, just an integer there.
Now, what I'll do is I'll hold down control while hovering over the variable.
And then I'm going to go into left mouse drag and let go.
Now, you'll see that it's got spacing between how many bushes.
And it makes the naming convention easy to read.
Now, you could do spaces.
You don't need to do this, by the way.
But just to show you, you could do a space of how many bushes and hold control and drag it across.
And that's still fine.
But it's just good practice not to have spaces in your variable names.
It'll still work, but it's just not really good practice.
What you can also do is just not capitalize it.
But what you'll see very quickly, if I just say how many bushes, one.
And I'll drag and drop that in.
It just makes it harder to read.
So, that variable versus that variable, it's just better to capitalize, in my opinion.
So, just some good naming conventions there.
I'm just going to delete what I created.
And again, let's just compile and save.
Just let's get into the habit of compiling and saving.
So, what we want to do, we first want to make sure it's visible.
So, we're going to click this variable and then compile and save.
And then what I'm also going to do, just for organization, I'm going to create a category.
And maybe I'll call this construction script.
And now it's got a category called construction script here.
So, if you start creating blueprints, you'll find yourself creating maybe 20, 30 variables.
And if you don't start organizing from when you first create a blueprint,
and get some weirdly, excuse me, and you just want to keep things organized as you go.
So, again, let's compile and save.
And let's just get into the habit of compile, save, compile, save.
And then what we want to do is on our variable, we'll type 5.
So, in this example, we're going to create a series of bushes from a construction script.
And so, I want to create 5 in this example.
So, let's drag off and create a for loop.
So, from this execution pin on the constructor, I'm just going to left mouse drag
and type for loop and select the for loop.
I'm going to move that into position.
And on the first index, I'll type 1.
And on the last index, I'll drag and drop how many bushes into that.
So, it's between 1 and 5 because 5 is on our variable here.
So, what we want to do is we want to add some kind of random vectors to these bushes.
So, they get randomly placed around.
So, I'm going to right click in empty space.
I'm going to type random unit vector.
Select that first one, random unit vector.
I'm just going to hit enter on my keyboard.
And then, I'm going to multiply this.
So, I'm going to drag off the yellow pin.
I'm going to hold down shift and number 8 on my keyboard for a multiply sign.
It's a little star sign on my keyboard.
And then, multiply.
You can type in multiply.
But for any kind of math driven stuff, if you want to type, you know, equals or hold down shift
and equals, which is a plus key, you can do the math base command.
So, I'm just going to hold down shift and number 8, which is the star key on my keyboard.
I'm going to multiply there.
And then, we want to create a float to a variable and call it modifier.
So, I want to then right click the node here on the bottom left.
I'll convert the pin and I'll convert it to a float, which is a single precision one.
So, there we go.
We got our float variable here.
Now, what I'll do is I'll get my green float box here.
I'm going to drag off it to the left.
I'm going to create a variable.
So, I want to promote it to a variable.
So, I'll click that and it's automatically highlighted this text here.
So, if you've clicked off it, just click on it again or right click to rename.
But I'm just going to call this modifier.
And again, I'm going to set this category just to keep things organized.
So, I'll just go to construction scripts.
I'll compile and save just to make sure we're still happy here.
I'm going to move this modifier.
And that's our getting to our basic functionality now.
So, keeping things organized, compiling and saving.
And then, what we want to do is we want to find the different x, y, and z values of this vector.
So, I'm just going to drag off here.
I'm going to break the vector.
I'll just create a break vector here.
You don't need the 3f.
I'll just break the vector and move that into position.
And now, what I'll do is I'll drag off x and make vector as well.
So, I just want to make the vector again.
Now, why am I breaking and then making it straight back?
So, if I drag and drop into the y here, now I've got my x and y coordinates.
What you'll notice is we've broken the z.
We don't want to connect the z because if we're placing these brushes,
we want them placing along a flat surface.
In Unreal Engine, x and y are the two horizontal vectors.
z is the vertical vector.
So, we don't want anything being changed in z.
So, we've got that set up and then we want to create an add static mesh component.
So, off the loop body, I'm going to drag off here.
I'm going to add static mesh component.
So, again, this is a construction script.
Sorry.
We can add static mesh components at compile time.
So, we can see these appearing in the editor without playing,
which is really powerful functionality.
So, from relative transform, we can go into the return value of the mate vector
and it will automatically convert that for us.
So, we want to make sure that.
So, it goes from a yellow pin, which is a vector.
Into an orange variable, which is the transform value.
And then that sets up our basic construction script.
So, we'll still need to assign a mesh.
So, let's save, compile.
And let's make sure our modifier is at least one, for example, let's say.
We'll expose this as well, just in case.
Well, actually, I'll show you what happens if we don't expose it.
So, let's just save.
I'm going to drag and drop this next to my map example,
just so it's easy to switch between the two.
I'm going to find a static mesh in my content browser.
So, I'm just going to go to the content.
You can pick whichever mesh you'd like to use here.
I'm just going to filter by static mesh.
I'm just going to find something to use.
Maybe it's a pillar.
Let's use a bush, for example.
This will work with any static mesh, though.
I go back into my construction script.
I go to the add static mesh component,
and I'm going to put a mesh into here.
And then I'll compile and save.
Now, what I'm going to do is I go back to my blueprint folder.
If you've added any filters here, you just want to remove them by clicking them.
And then what you can do is you can drag and drop into the scene.
So, what we'll do is we'll duplicate this.
And so, you'll see that, first of all, how many bushes is five here.
And what you'll notice is we don't see the modifier functionality.
So, if I go back into the construction script,
on modifier, I can promote this variable and expose it.
So, variable is now public.
If I compile and save, now you'll see that modifier value,
which is going to be really powerful because now we can add light color properties,
or we could change many different variables at runtime.
You can change these per instance.
So, if I say how many bushes and I want two, for example,
that still stays at five.
Five is still there because it's an instance.
When we're talking about instancing on the level script,
each one of these can house its own variable data now,
which is really cool and powerful functionality.
Then the last thing we want to do is just change the modifier value.
So, say you want two bushes and say the modifier is 50, for example, or maybe 100.
That will still have two bushes, but now there are 100 units apart.
So, for example, in this five-bush one, let's say 300,
and that will make five bushes 300 units apart.
So, you can see all the powerful functionality.
And the constructor will fire every time we move the blueprint around,
which we mentioned in our previous slides.
The constructor fires whenever you move it in the blueprint.
So, this is really powerful functionality,
especially when you're trying to place grass along a hill.
You can just keep duplicating.
So, I'm going to hold Alt and left mouse drag on the widget.
And you can imagine the powerful use here,
where maybe you have exposed the static mesh property, for example,
or maybe you expose the scale.
So, you can, as they're constructing, maybe you scale a mesh between 0.2 units
and maybe three units.
So, not only are they randomizing the location,
but they're also randomizing the scale.
You could even randomize the rotation so they get different values.
You could add slight pitches and change the yaw
so that they just have a very random feel to the place in the bushes.
So, again, constructor can be super powerful.
I hope that was a good introduction to the construction script.
It's definitely worth playing around and really figuring out
how to use that construction script because, again,
it can improve those processes massively.